si tu me dis le mot je te dirais le
reste et je marche le match au milieu
des silences ses deux jours en du
festival de cannes 2010 9
[Musique]
c'était un hélicoptère posé près de la
mer c'était un escabeau posé près du
palais près des marches et c'était un
tapis rouge
enroulez condé rôle qu'on déroule qu'on
déroule qu'on déroule c'était un flash
ces thèmes il flashe c'était des passes
était démarche c'était une pause un
sourire une autre pause c'était bijoux
s'était coiffée recoiffer et des robes
et des robes et des robes et des robes
et c'était des smokings ses terres
c'était aussi c'était surtout
[Musique]
à
angèle ouvrière au piano la grande
cérémonie aux côtés d'edouard baer pour
un morceau de classe et de mélancolie
nous l'avons retrouvé ailleurs près d'un
autre piano celui de la terrasse albane
pour une auto interview
pouvez vous adresser un message au monde
pour lui dire de bonnes raisons de tout
quitter quinze jours pour venir sur la
croisette
bonjour le monde est en belle je
pourrais parler premièrement du beau
temps et ensuite de la couleur de la mer
voilà je pense que c'est très très
bonnes raisons de venir pour y croire
il faudra tout
toto un jour
j'ai toujours
ce bonheur
je me le
vous allez maintenant lire plusieurs
textes à trous
vous n'aurez qu'à lire et complétée
d'accord pour moi aujourd'hui je suis à
cannes enfin pour être plus précise je
suis angèle ce soir j'aimerais bien
manger et bien dormir mais je n'aimerais
pas vraiment faire une insomnie et quand
je regarde vers la mer je me dis que
malheureusement elle monte ailleurs plus
loin encore dans les suites d hôtel
légendaire se trouve des acteurs des
actrices ceux du premier film à
s'élancer dans la compétition officielle
de dettes d'hendaye de jim jarmusch
chloë sevigny tilda swinton bill murray
[Musique]
de gauche sont plus lourdes
on aurait pu vous montrer ça on aurait
pu vous montrer ça aussi mais comme on
n'a plus le temps aujourd'hui qu'elle
vous dit
[Musique]